Nicola jokic might be a two-time MVP and
an NBA champion but he's also the only
NBA player who got drafted during a Taco
Bell commercial coming into the draft
Scouts admired his court vision and
passing but didn't hold back on how much
athleticism he lacked but the Denver
Nuggets were also in need of a new
Direction after finishing the season 30
and 52 and missing out on the playoffs
for a second straight year there's only
so much time in between second round
picks meaning commercials are bound to
pop up to keep viewers engaged
throughout while the Nuggets were taking
a swing at the unknown Prospect the new
quesarito commercial for Taco Bell ran
stealing the spotlight from the 41st
pick little did they know that Nicola
jokic would later be that spark that the
franchise needed and has since developed
into one of the best big men in NBA
history his consistent play and
hard-working mentality while also
leading the Nuggets to their first title
in franchise history was no easy
accomplishment jokic might be the
biggest steal in NBA draft history but
he'll definitely be the only NBA MVP
drafted during a Taco Bell commercial